[Music]
what's up everybody michael here now it
shouldn't be a surprise
that we're obsessed with adult animation
and with how seemingly silly shows like
rick and morty south park and bojack
horseman can actually teach us a lot
about some pretty serious stuff from
depression to gentrification to
emotionally processing that your mom
might be a clone but we've yet to touch
on the adult animation show that's not
afraid to throw some meat on the grill
king of the hill this slice of tex and
suburban life ran for over a decade in
the late 90s and early 2000s and while
it holds a special place in the hearts
of its fans it hasn't commanded the same
grip on the cultural conversation as its
contemporaries like the simpsons or
family guy and that may be because the
hill family and their neighbors aren't
often exploring lofty philosophical
ideas over their cold cans of american
lager there's no alcoholic grandpa to
give us nihilistic musings on the
universe and none of the episodes end
with someone saying but i've learned
something today in fact the show's
creator mike judge has said that he
specifically avoids injecting any
political messaging into his work we'd
argue that office space is definitely a
political film but who are we to
disagree with mr judge i'm tired of
being pushed around
aren't you yes peter but i'm not going
to do anything illegal illegal samir
this is america but does that mean that
the show is completely apolitical is it
even possible for a television show to
skirt politics entirely after all
kingdom health's characters are often
thrown into very political situations
and their world views are shaped by
their experiences so i see you finally
got luanne involved in politics that's
good
ass
the paper united stand
tommy go home and it's safe to say there
are very few television characters who
are as consistent and steadfast in their
values as hank hill what if somebody
wants theirs well done we ask them
politely yet firmly to leave it's easy
to read the show simply as a caricature
of conservative families in texas and
plenty of people do but is there a
deeper message hidden in the musings of
these working-class sweethearts let's
find out on this wisecrack edition on
king of the hill deep or dumb for the
uninitiated or forgetful king of the
hill depicts a fictional central texas
suburb called arlen and specifically the
hill family consisting of hank peggy and
their son bobby hank is an all-american
man's man he was a teen football star
married his high school sweetheart and
settled down in his hometown unlike
other animated sitcom dads with names
like homer or peter hank isn't portrayed
as an oafish slob who's barely keeping
his family intact instead he's a
principled loving patriarch who serves
as a moral center not only for his
family but also for his community he
believes in hard work family values and
of course the supremacy of propane over
any other fuel source you brought
charcoal into our house i didn't know
what it was luanne asked me to hold it
for her i thought it was drugs much of
the central conflict of the show comes
from hank's stalwart ways clashing
against the world's changing social and
political landscape conflicts can ensue
from everything from sex education in
public schools what sexual education
where'd you get this to eco-friendly
toilets
still that's not to say that hank is
overtly conservative at the very least
he seems to believe in climate change
it's already 110 in the summer and if it
gets one degree hotter i'm gonna kick
your ass and he acknowledges that
americans stole their land from
indigenous peoples i agree that stealing
indians land was wrong can't you agree
that eating people is wrong it may be
this moderate political positioning that
makes hank such an endearing character
to those all over the political spectrum
and why some critics have called king of
the hill the last bipartisan tv comedy
so is the show trying to extol the
values of moderate conservatism well not
exactly hank's behavior isn't guided by
his political leanings or his religious
beliefs even though he is a god-fearing
man i know god's up there and he knows
i'm smack dab in the middle of the
second pew instead he tends to make
decisions based on a combination of
conventional wisdom and an innate sense
of right and wrong now this doesn't
always lead to the correct decision in
fact hank nearly misses out on voting in
a presidential election because his
candidate had a flimsy
god
his handshake
it's limp as many times as hank is
portrayed as his family and friend's
moral guide he is just as often put in
situations where he has to compromise
some of these values in order to live a
fulfilling life and care for his family
this is especially true when it comes to
his relationship with his son bobby that
boy ain't right despite hank's best
efforts to pass down his brand of
masculinity bobby is most fulfilled when
he's performing prop comedy or stage
magic or ventriloquism his attempts to
push bobby into sports or other more
masculine coded pursuits only
deteriorates their relationship these
moments often cause hank to reflect on
his relationship with his own father who
he begins to realize might not have been
the best role model you know how i was
raised what my father's like
i got my shin blown off by japan man's
machine gun so don't come crying to me
with your problem most of these episodes
end with hank feeling content that at
least bobby has found his own niche in
society even if that means taking on
roles that hank considers more feminine
like when bobby shows an aptitude for
cooking and cleaning after taking a home
economics class if bobby learns to cook
and clean for himself what's his
motivation to ever get married this
speaks to what may be the underlying
theme of the whole series time and time
again hank's black and white values and
sense of identity are tested against the
tides of an increasingly complex and
diversified world which begs the
question what value do our political and
cultural ideologies have if they don't
help us function in our day-to-day lives
to find out we need to examine the work
of someone that hank hill would probably
ask to leave his barbecue but whose
ideas he might ultimately agree with
henry lefebvre was a french
marxist
philosopher
who also likely preferred a nice glass
of room temperature red wine to an ice
cold bud in his work the critique of
everyday life lefeb tried to bring
marxist theory into the experiences of
everyday working class people he became
increasingly frustrated with
intellectuals who seemed more interested
in pontificating about the values of the
working class than actually listening to
the experiences of workers he used the
example of an urban intellectual
strolling the french countryside
lamenting the plight of the peasant
farmer without ever experiencing the
hard labor it takes to work the land or
the centuries of cultivation it took to
shape it because the everyday is where
most life happens it's a sight of
transformative conflict worth taking
seriously more than anything he thought
that because capitalism is constantly
reproducing itself via the everyday
revolutionizing our day-to-day existence
was a precondition for any type of
future utopian society now hank is
definitely not a marxist i hate
communists all they do is boss people
around sounds like you uncle hank but he
is a working-class guy whose livelihood
is often put in jeopardy by the forces
of capitalism he swears undying loyalty
to his boss and mentor buck strickland
even though he delegates most of the
actual work of running the shop to hank
while he spends his time drinking
gambling and philandering hank only
stands up to his boss when his immoral
ways threaten to rub off on bobby but
this isn't the only time hank struggles
against the forces of the free market
when the corporate superstore megalomart
threatens to put strickland propane out
of business hank laments the takeover of
local economies by these corporate
behemoths the only place you can find a
main street these days is in disneyland
just try to buy a gun there and when
that same superstore threatens the
quality of the town's meat supply he
even goes so far as to join a hippie
infested co-op just to get quality
stakes it's clear that hank is willing
to put aside his conservative reputation
when it comes to meeting the everyday
needs of his family and community when a
major back injury keeps him away from
work he not only applies for workers
compensation workers comp do i look like
a hobo to you he even joins a yoga
studio yoga
isn't that a cult above all hank values
hard work and while this may sometimes
blind him to how much his own labor is
being exploited by his boss it also
makes him keenly aware of the needs of
other working-class folks in his
community these people may have a
multitude of ideological differences but
at the end of the day they have more in
common with each other than they do with
megalomart or other external forces like
the government for example when the
public schools are forced to teach sex
education what do you know about sexual
relations
i don't know
nothing much
i'm a little worried about being a [ __ ]
while these forces may initially sway
some residents to their side by the end
of the episode it's the sense of
community that wins out and brings the
characters back together like when peggy
makes hella banks selling homes to
hipsters who want to live in a diverse
neighborhood but eventually she realizes
that she's been contributing to the
gentrification that almost forced hank's
co-worker enrique out of his home so she
remedies the situation i own my own
house i am a homeowner now i pay
mortgage instead of rent left might
describe this as the people of arlen
exerting their right to the city
according to him urban space was not the
product of the private entity who may
own it or even the state authority who
may govern it instead it is the product
of the people who inhabit the space the
food being cooked the language is being
spoken and the cultures being displayed
are all part of what makes an urban or
even suburban space thrive while cities
and neighborhoods may be built with the
backing of capital interests and ruled
over by local and federal governments
above all they're social experiments and
while the people of ireland aren't often
seen squatting in vacant buildings or
chaining themselves to construction
equipment although they do occasionally
engage in direct action they assert
their own right to the city in many
different ways these include legal
methods like when hank joins the zoning
board to repeal a ban on high flow
toilets and some less than legal methods
like when the residents tear down a
prefab house in their neighborhood when
its structural integrity threatens their
own homes while the majority of the
population of ireland has key
demographics in common the protagonists
of the show are not in the business of
imposing their world view onto the town
as a whole they simply want to be able
to live their lives in the way that best
suits them while also looking out for
the collective good of the community
they may scoff at environmentalist
hippies or poke fun at gay rodeo clowns
but they ultimately want to create a
space where all people can live their
best lives a lot has changed since king
of the hill went off the air the
political climate in the country has
become just a tad bit more polarized and
with the ever-growing influence of
social media political identities are
being formed in an arena that is far
removed from everyday in-person
interactions it's never been easier to
avoid your cousin jason at family
functions because he spammed you with
flat earther videos in your dms when you
don't have to physically interact with
someone with differing viewpoints it's
much easier to write them off and this
is precisely where we can still glean
some wisdom from king of the hill
because at first glance it's easy to
assume the show's message is the
importance of putting aside our
preconceived notions about people we
don't know and then working with them to
create communities that benefit us all
and on its face it may seem like this
finding common ground narrative is pure
political fantasy but what the hill
family and their neighbors show us is
that our everyday beliefs matter in big
ways so while we might think of
exploring various political ideologies
online as a type of cosplay it can have
real effects on our personal lives and
ultimately upon our wider communities
it's not an either or between the
everyday or the political but of both
and in which these spheres are
inextricably linked which means that if
we're open-minded and kind to our fellow
redditors we're helping to shape a
kinder world offline but if we're being
vengeful ideological dicks on social
media we're creating an echo chamber
that encourages a vibe of vengeful
dickishness to spread its wings in the
real world overall king of the hills
focus on the politics of everyday life
and the way it shows us how to use these
politics to assert our right to our own
spaces earns it a wisecrack certified
label of pretty deep but what do you all
think are we reading too much into a
show that spends a significant amount of
its air time on scenes like this yep
yep
yep or can the lives of these animated
texans teach us all how to live simpler
yet more fulfilling lives let us know in
the comments and thanks as always to our
amazing patrons for all your support and
don't forget to check out our new
updated patreon page also be sure to
check out our new stream wisecrack live
right here every thursday smash that
subscribe button like it's an empty can
of alamo beer and don't forget to ring
that bell and as always thanks for
watching later
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you